Creo que es el mejor guión que he hecho nunca, ha dicho José Alberto Chozas al empezar este
vídeo antes de empezarlo.
No sé si eso pone el listo muy alto o muy bajo, pero hoy aquí en La Media Inglesa,
ex jugadores de la Premier que siguen jugando en el barro, en ligas no inferiores, muy inferiores.
Un momento, un momento, antes de que arranque el vídeo, dejadme contaros que se acerca
un nuevo viaje de La Media Inglesa al fin de semana, el 18 y 19 de octubre.
Viajamos a Inglaterra para vivir en directo un nuevo partido del Harvard,
tal como hicimos la temporada pasada.
Por solo 289 euros, se incluye todo el fin de semana.
El viernes saldremos desde Londres en autobús hacia Leicester.
Esa noche ya estaremos ahí en Leicester tomando unas cervecillas.
Sábado haremos un tour por Leicester por la mañana, nos iremos a Harvard para ver el partido
y por la noche, los que hayan venido a otros viajes, ya saben lo que les espera.
Domingo, regreso a Londres.
¿Qué incluyen esos 289 euros?
Lo que no incluyen son los vuelos, pero sí todos los traslados en autobús,
dos noches de hotel, desayuno y por supuesto la entrada al partido.
Con el enlace que tenéis aquí abajo podéis comprar vuestro viaje para acompañarnos
para ir juntos con toda la comunidad de La Media Inglesa a vivir este partido el 18 de octubre.
Esperamos.
Chozas, dinos, ¿es el mejor guión que has hecho nunca?
Lo cual no implica que sea bueno.
Yo solo he dicho que es el mejor que he hecho hasta ahora.
¿Cuál es el guión, cuál es la explicación?
Cuéntanos.
Vamos a ver, me he puesto a bucear en las carreras de los futbolistas
a ver qué exjugadores de la Premier League están ahora mismo
en las divisiones más bajas que he podido encontrar,
lo más abajo, lo más al fondo posible.
Lo más abajo.
Lo más abajo, lo más abajo.
Hay auténticas barbaridades, o sea hay octavas divisiones de países bajos.
Vale, vale, nos gusta, nos gusta.
Me ha llevado a esto, por supuesto, el primero de nuestros nombres.
Luego lo llevaremos, pero claro.
Es un vídeo en el que evidentemente teníamos que empezar
por un hombre que se debe al pueblo.
Es un hombre que se debe al pueblo, se cansó de la élite y se fue con las gentes.
No, se cansó el de la élite.
Claro, amigos, es que el jugador con el que empezamos,
sí, ahí lo estáis viendo en su época en el Liverpool,
pero no es lo que nos interesa en este vídeo
porque el ex de Liverpool, Newcastle y West Ham United
jugó su último partido de Premier League en 2021 con los Magpies,
de hecho, y a partir de entonces se le dio a la gente.
Y tanto que se le dio a la gente.
Ha pasado por el Reading, por el West Brom en Champions League,
no es una división tan baja, por el Amiens en segunda división francesa,
sigue sin ser algo tan bajo, y aquí ya bajamos a cuarta división
con el Girondins de Bourdeau.
¡Cuidado!
Girondins de Bourdeau.
De Bourdeau.
De verdad, cada vez que te metes con el tema del francés,
montas unos pollos que son para alucinar.
¿Pero cómo que Bourdeau?
Yo lo utilizo, estos vídeos de Duolingo.
Será Bourdeau, es mi Duolingo.
Bourdeau o Bourdeos, pero Bourdeau,
de verdad, eres el tío con menos vergüenza que he visto nunca
para pronunciar en francés.
Jesús dile algo, tío.
En la vida ni que tener vergüenza, tío.
Jesús dile algo.
Bourdeau.
El Girondins de Bourdeau.
En cuarta división estuvo jugando Andy Carroll el año pasado,
marcó 11 goles, pero eso sí, no logró ascenderlos.
¿Y qué pasa?
Que este verano se ha cansado y ha dicho,
me voy a ir más cerca de mis hijos,
porque estoy harto de tenerlos tan lejos,
se ha fichado, por el Daganred de tercera,
o sea, uy, de tercera, ya les gustaría,
de sexta división inglesa, ahí estamos viendo
al bono de Andy Carroll con la camiseta del Daganred.
Has estado a punto, de forma inconsciente,
de sacar a mi hermano, a nuestro hermano,
a Odey Martín en esta foto, porque Odey juega en el Worthing.
Anda.
Y justo es un partido contra el Worthing.
Has estado a punto, manche.
A puntito.
Joder, habría molado.
La camiseta mola que es un pase.
Habría molado muchísimo.
La camiseta es guapísima.
¿Cuál era la de este año?
La del Worthing.
Ah, vale, vale.
Con Odey detrás.
Pero has estado muy cerca de manera inconsciente.
Sí, sí, sí.
Ojalá haberlo...
Claro, ojalá haber tenido a Odey
junto a Andy Carroll en una misma foto.
Habría molado.
Bueno, sexta inglesa, ¿eh?
Sexta inglesa.
Dijo el bueno de Andy Carroll que le habían llamado
seis o siete clubes de Liga superiores,
pero que quería ir a un club que tuviera el encaje correcto.
Tú dime a mí qué narices es el encaje correcto.
Bueno, pues te lo digo yo,
que ha entrado a formar parte de la nueva propiedad del Daganred.
Ahí está, que es un fondo de inversión catarí.
Y ha dicho que tienen un proyecto para sacarlos de la non-league.
Ya te adelanto que no les está yendo muy bien.
No, no.
El bueno de Andy Carroll no debutó en partido oficial
hasta la jornada 8 contra el Wharton,
que lo estábamos viendo ahí por lesión.
Bueno, primer partido de Andy Carroll,
suplente, salen el minuto 63 para buscar la remontada
y van perdiendo 1-2, terminan perdiendo 2-5.
Ya, que fue bien.
Vale, días después, primera titularidad,
bien por Andy.
Las noticias fueron en todo el país,
Andy Carroll debuta con el Daganred,
bueno, minuto 45, le expulsan por un codazo
y el Bedford termina empatando en el descuento,
en F&K.
A tomar por culo.
Andy, hijo.
Andy.
He ido, por supuesto, al tweet
donde en el Daganred ponían
Andy Carroll ha sido expulsado
para ver la ponzoña más absoluta
del descojone vivo de los aficionados.
Vamos a verlos.
Ahí está.
Imagínate contarle esto a alguien en 2011.
Ed, aficionado del Liverpool.
Hombre, fliparía.
Claro, fliparía en colores.
Estaría claro.
Siguiente reacción al tweet.
Puedes sacar a un cico de Newcastle.
Pero no a Newcastle del chaval.
No podrás.
Y ahora, por supuesto,
a mis favoritas,
porque son varias diciendo lo mismo.
Ahí está, de vuelta Ibiza.
Supongo que Ibiza...
Es que en Ibiza hace calor todavía.
Y ahora podrá irse, por supuesto,
de vacaciones con su novia.
Dan no está muy de acuerdo con el fichaje
por parte de Dagan a Red Bridge
de Andy Carroll.
No está muy de acuerdo.
Bueno, fantástico.
Bueno, te informo que pudo jugar el replay
de esa eliminatoria de FA Cup como titular
porque la sanción le empezó a computar
siete días después en Liga
y fue clave en el único gol del encuentro
después de que un cabezazo suyó en un corner,
se estrellaron en el palo, rebotaron en un compañero
y se metieron para adentro para darle el pase
al Dagan a Red.
Asistencia, tal y como yo lo entiendo.
Andy Carroll, que es muy querido en
burdeos, burdeó, según
aquí nuestro amigo Andy Carroll
de la media inglesa, José Alberto Chozas,
que es ahí bastante respetado
por lo que hizo allí, si no me equivoco.
Yo que sé, quemase un colegio y yo que sé.
Hasta donde tengo entendido, no quemó ningún colegio.
No es algo que haya hecho en burdeos.
Y ahora está en los Dagan Red
intentando levantar al equipo.
Vámonos con otro futbolista
que también recordaréis y que es de estos que dicen
son meses raras, tirado hace 700 millones de años.
Pues no, amigos, Janem Villa sigue jugando
al fútbol. Aquí lo tenéis en pantalla
al ex futbolista
del Sunderland. Jugo
cedido en la temporada 15-16 en los
Black Cats y fue titular en 36
partidos. Él quería quedarse y Sam Alardais
también quería que se quedara, pero no consiguieron llegar
a un acuerdo con el Rubin Kazan.
Y ya me acuerdo que Janem Villa llegó a sonar
incluso para equipos grandes tipo Real Madrid
en su día. Era una cosa bastante
bestia y bueno, al final se quedó por el camino como podéis ver.
Tenemos un post de Instagram
de Janem Villa que no sé por dónde va.
Después de que se anunciara
que no le iban a fichar,
se daba por hecho que le iban a fichar
que le querían, no terminaron llegando
a un acuerdo y este es el post de Janem Villa
después de que sucediera aquello.
He llamado al Sunderland, pero nadie
me coge el teléfono porque mi corazón
está roto. Madre mía Jan.
Pobrecito.
Le jodieron la vida. Nadie le coge al
teléfono a Janem Villa.
Saltaba el contestador.
¿A quién no le ha saltado alguna vez el contestador
cuando quería que le cojeran el teléfono, verdad?
Jan. Pobrecito.
Y lo pone en Instagram. Hay que hacer.
¿Pero esto de qué año es?
Esto es de 2016. Existían
las stories de Instagram ya hace 10 años.
Lo que pasa que tú
todavía creo que no llega al archivo,
todavía no existían las archivadas, lo de que podías ver tus stories.
Pero sí existían esas stories.
Pero aquí clavaron un pantallazo.
Acabo pasando por Sanetienne,
Olympiacos, West Bromwich Albion y
Kong.
Bien pronunciado. Gracias.
Gracias como inspector.
Es que ni siquiera eres ya profesor
y es inspector de francés.
Kong que ha extendido por cierto a tercera división francesa.
Es la primera vez en 40 años que le pasa al
Kong. El club es propiedad de
Kylian Mbappé desde 2024 y fue el que
llamó a Mbilla para ficharlo.
No ha salido muy bien la cosa. Ahí lo tenéis con una barba
que da la gloria de verla.
Increíble.
Camiseta muy
Crystal Palace.
Acabo de ver. Supongo que la
publicidad tiene algo que ver con
lavado de coches. Starwars.
¿Tú crees?
Sí, un poquito juego de palabras. Starwars,
Starwars. La verdad es que bien tocado.
A ver, el juego de palabras bien tocado ahora.
¿A qué se dedicará a Starwars?
Es eso el lavado de dinero.
Starwars.
Muy bien tocado. Cuidado, hay uno
en la gavia. No jodas. Servicio
de lavado de coches. El mejor auto lavado
del ensanche de Obayecas. Cuidado porque esto
tiene pinta de que no es
una multinacional, sino
que aquí todo el mundo hace el juego de palabras.
A tope con el juego de palabras.
Lo que dices es que no
Starwars de Obayecas
no es el Starwars
de camiseta. Ha cogido ahí un
hermano de Obayecas y ha dicho, espera, a mí
me ha molado que te cagas
y si quieren venir a reclamarle se van a cruzar con mis puños.
Y van a tener problemas.
Sí, yo no iría a reclamarle a mi hermano
del ensanche de Obayecas porque es un
tipo con un par de huevos. Si ya ha hecho
lo de Starwars saltándose,
la licencia de Starwars, Josh Lucas
ahí detrás de él, detrás de Antonio
del ensanche de Obayecas y también
la empresa Starwars, si tiene esos huevos
yo no iría detrás de él. A ver que a lo mejor
ha cogido a Kilian Mbappé, lo vio
y yo me puse en Obayecas de gusto como el limpiado en el coche y dije
dinero para ti.
Tras el descenso
que hace que juegue a la tercera
división francesa, si no me equivoco
Janem Villa, dijo, cuando un club como este
termina último en segunda división es porque los jugadores
son una mierda. Nunca hemos visto
algo parecido. En el Sunderland
peleábamos por salvarnos y había
11 leones en el campo, pero aquí no
tenemos esa determinación
ni ese fútbol. En términos de
coeficiente intelectual estamos en nuestro lugar.
Hostia, el vestuario roto.
Acaba de llamar sus normales a todos sus compañeros.
A toda la plantilla.
¿Alguna culpa tendrás tú también?
Ha dicho que son una mierda y que son retrasados.
Totalmente, tío.
En términos de coeficiente intelectual
estamos en nuestro lugar que es ser últimos
de segunda. Cuidado.
Bueno, sigue jugando en tercera
y de momento bastante titular.
Pero bastante buena pinta tiene el club.
Por supuesto, tiene una pinta.
Un equipo sin coeficiente
intelectual es lo que dice Janem Villa que es el con.
Vamos con nuestro siguiente nombre
de la lista que tiene una historia que me
encanta que es Jermen Lens.
Aquí le estamos viendo el extremo neerlandés
que jugó
20 partidos de Premier League con el Sunderland
en la 15-16, la misma que
Janem Villa fichado por Dick
Advocate. Cuidado que le fichó
al principio de temporada que le había
entrenado en el PSV y en el
AZ y dijo, vente para acá.
Si no me equivoco en catalán, Advocate
es... no sé cómo se pronuncia pero es
abogado.
O abocado.
Si mezclas idiomas
en realidad lo que te sale con este nombre
es que es un pene abogado.
Es un pene que se dedica a la abogacía
Dick Advocate. Ya está, es un detalle
lingüístico. Bien detallado.
El pene abogado.
Tú eres
supervisor de todos los idiomas.
De todos los idiomas. Menos del francés que es mi
parcela. Solo falta que ahora me venga un
catalán y me diga, pues no tiene nada que ver.
Espero que no sea así.
Yo tengo el ceo no de catalán,
he convivido mucho con Jordi Furriola.
Es un catalán chusco pero es un catalán.
Hace poco nos dimos cuenta de que nunca nos había
corregido algo que decíamos mal.
No, no, no.
Es el villano de una historia mal contada.
Porque no era lo mismo como se pronunciaba
en catalán y en valenciano.
Una palabra que ya no recuerdo.
Pero esto es así. Entonces mi catalán sigue
impoluto. Las tres palabras que sé.
Pero construyo cosas.
No sé construir cosas.
Verán los comentarios ahora.
Nunca ha sido abogado en catalán
ni parecido. Ya verás.
Creo que es así. 100%.
Dejadme en paz. Y si he acertado
por favor decídmelo en comentarios. Si no he acertado
no me lo dejáis.
Cuenta de más cosas del pene abogado.
Era titularísimo
hasta que en la jornada 8, siendo colistas
y sin haber ganado todavía un partido,
iban ganando 2-0 al West Ham.
Le expulsaron a German Lenz.
Acabaron empatándoles. Despidieron a Zvokat.
Y con Alardijs, apenas jugó,
dijo Alardijs, eres un mierda.
Han despedido al entrenador que te trajo
por tu culpa. Ahora te quedas sin jugar.
Después de esto, pasó por Turquía
y tercera francesa.
Y ha acabado, ojo,
en el Real Esranang
de octava división
de países bajos.
Ahí ha acabado. Octava división de países bajos.
Acabó en novena, lo que pasa que
el año pasado ascendieron y ahora están en octava.
Pero empiezo a pensar que no estamos
muy lejos ninguno de los que estamos aquí
de la novena división holandesa.
No, no, pero que esto es fútbol
hiper extra mateo.
Novena división holandesa, Jesús,
¿tú jugarías en la novena división holandesa?
Pero por poco.
Ah, por poco solo. Uy, Jesús le ha dado la vena humilde hoy.
Qué raro esto.
Yo pensaba decir que no jugaría, pero porque él no quiere.
No, claro. Rechazaría el contrato
del Real Esranang. Esto es que hace poco a Juan Partiz nos ha visto bien.
Sí. Aquí hay bajón físico.
No se ha visto rápido, eh. Porque si no
Jesús tal y como conocemos a Jesús
La bala Sánchez. La bala Sánchez.
Hostia, la bala Sánchez que ahora se ha convertido
en la pala Sánchez.
Sólo se recoge a sí mismo.
Qué elección, Jesús.
Bueno, pues nada, una división que es muy baja
pero todavía en esa división no jugaría Jesús Sánchez.
No jugaría Jesús. Tú y yo sí.
Yo creo que sí. Sí, yo me veo jugando.
Una novena división holandesa. Me veo jugando.
Bueno, te informo de que el Real Esranang
es un club fundado por inmigrantes
Surinameses en Amsterdam.
Esranang en una lengua criolla de Surinam
significa Surinam.
¿Sabes el nombre del propio país?
O sea que esto sería el Real Surinam.
Juegan en Amsterdam, Lens nació en Amsterdam
pero sus padres son Surinameses
e incluso él ha llegado a jugar partidos
no oficiales con la selección Surinamesa
antes de debutar con la absoluta debatida
de la selección Surinamese.
Y es que es un club que se ha convertido en una
un club que se ha convertido en una
es una de las más importantes
de debutantes de debutar
con la absoluta de países bajos.
Ahí estamos viendo abajo a la izquierda
al bueno de German Lens.
Es un equipo, por cierto,
en el que jugaron los padres
de Seedorf, Kluivert, Reijard y Gullit.
Todo salado. Espectacular.
Y de portero está 30 Alexander Arnold.
Fantástico. Adelgazado un poquito.
Y Brian Mbembo.
Pero bueno, esto es una estrella.
Mbembo es literalmente Ryan Mbembo.
¿Cuánto dinero tiene esta gente para atraer a tantas estrellas?
¡Guau!
La ha ido mal, 30 en el Madrid.
Para tener que irse a jugar.
Y Mbembo ha acabado hasta las pelotas de Amaurín.
Me voy a países bajos.
Qué carisma en ese momento.
¿Has visto el once o no el entrenador?
¿Sabes quién es el entrenador?
Danzel Grabenberg. ¿Te suena el apellido?
No me jodas, es el primo. Es el hermano.
Es el hermano de Ryan Grabenberg.
Es increíble. Es increíble porque
como lo decía su padre, el padre de ellos
hay un fin de semana
que se va a ver jugar al Real Isra'nan
a octava división de Holanda
y luego al día siguiente, a la semana siguiente
está en Anfield viendo a Ryan.
Tiene mucho mérito el reparto de tiempo de anfield.
La verdad que sí. Porque es completamente justo el reparto
entre Ryan y Danzel. Es completamente justo.
Este hombre le encanta ir. Hoy toca, lo siento Ryan
sé que jugáis en Anfield contra el Manchester City
pero es que toca a partido de tu hermano.
El Real Isra'nan se la juega contra el cuarto.
Toca a partido de tu hermano. Ese padre tiene ganas al cielo.
Hombre que si tiene ganas al cielo.
Has vencenoso al padre, la madre directamente
decide no elegir ninguno de los dos partidos y así no se enfada a Danzel.
La madre se la pela al fútbol lo más grande.
La madre ha dicho mira, para no tener que comerme
los partidos de Danzel, sacrifico los partidos de Ryan.
Te voy a decir por qué va la madre.
La madre solo va allí a comer
donde el bueno de Danzel
o donde Ryan no sé qué hace
en Anfield no sé qué hace.
En Anfield, quiero decirte, el buffet de Anfield malo no es.
No es malo. Pero nada comparado
con las sopas a Oto que sirven
en la cocina del estadio del Real Isra'nan
que es una comida típica
de Surinam y que la sirven
religiosamente después de cada partido
y que los clubes visitantes se quedan a comerla
después del partido.
No me digas que no hay foto de la sopa surinamesa.
Al menos la receta o algo.
No le he querido mirar porque es algo tan suyo
que yo no quiero decirle a la gente
cómo tiene que hacer una cosa de Surinam.
Que no haga la gente desde México
a apropiación cultural.
No me seas. Justo he elegido un país que...
No digo, pero que justo he elegido un país
cuya cocina se ha dedicado
a todo el mundo a hacer la apropiación cultural.
Es verdad.
Que solo un mexicano de México
¡Ah! Voy a este mexicano. ¿Esto qué es?
Bueno, amigos mexicanos.
Vamos a ver porque me ha llamado la atención
muchísimo el mejor once de jugadores
con raíces surinamesas.
Vas a flipar. Muy bueno, ¿no?
En portería, Born. ¡Hombre! El mítico del Tottenham.
Vale. Defensa.
Raysiger, Bogarde, Van Dijk.
¡Guau! Buenísimo esto.
Bogarde, no preguntes por el Chelsea.
Sí, no preguntes.
Pero en Surinam sí pregunta.
En el centro del campo
doble pivote para Fran Rijkaard y Klanen Sidor.
Arriba
en una línea de tres mediapuntas
Edgar Davids, Ruth Gullit y Vignaldo.
Gio. Por la cara.
Nunca había escuchado soy Gio para Vignaldo.
Yo tampoco. Y ahí estaba.
Y Jimmy Hasselbein con Patrick Kluivert.
Arriba. Increíble.
Todos estos tienen raíces.
Que te gana una liga y una Champions.
Aquí en este once hay unos cuantos
que ganaron la Champions con el Ajax.
Y ganaron la Eurocopa con Países Bajos.
Y luego por su lado. Claro, sí.
Pero increíble.
Bueno, amigos, pues ahí tenéis
nuestro amigo Lens que también
anda jugando por el barro, más barro
de las categorías
inferiores neerlandesas.
Vámonos ahora a uno que
a lo mejor os acordáis de él más por la selección
española, que es el Jero Elía.
Ahí lo tenéis.
El ex futbolista del Southampton
extremo neerlandés.
También con raíces surinamesas.
No me cabía en ese once.
Ya veis.
El imperialismo de Europa.
Tiene esas cosas.
Las raíces.
Los tentáculos.
Además de jugar la final
del Mundial de 2010.
Por lo que os decía que os acordaréis
de los futbolistas aquí al final siendo españoles.
Jugó media temporada cedido en el Southampton.
Yo este me acuerdo que en su día tenía muy buena pinta.
El Jero Elía y luego pues nada.
Juega la final del Mundial.
Para lo que parecía.
Un fichaje que
se convirtió en muy importante para Ronald Koeman.
Bueno, en el que Koeman fue muy importante
porque siendo neerlandés fue él el que lo rey dio para el sofá.
Eso fue importante para Koeman.
Juega 17 partidos y marcó 2 goles.
Luego la cosa pues...
No.
No se quedó porque consideraron muy cara la opción de compra de nuestro amigo El Jero.
Después pasó por el Vassac Seyhir.
Un equipo por el que pasan todos los elieros Elías de la vida.
Y varios clubes de países bajos como el Feyenoord.
Con el que ganó una copa y se la tatuó.
Pero Chozas...
Temo por lo que viene a continuación.
Porque has puesto que hubo problemas.
Hubo problemas. Vamos a ver la imagen del tatuaje.
Bueno, te la explico porque desde aquí no se ve muy bien.
El Jero es un equipo que se ha convertido en un equipo de fútbol.
Y es un equipo que se ha convertido en un equipo de fútbol.
Y abajo te informo que...
Tuvo que borrar la foto y subir el siguiente post con...
A ver Jesús, pasamos...
Estoy pasando muchísima vergüenza, ¿eh?
Ahí está, ahí está, ya corregido con Feynor.
Y abajo casi que parece Tipex el 04.
Es increíble, increíble.
Pero...
Le pusieron Fenn en un tío.
A ver, tengo que reconocerle al tatuador que aún así...
Maestro a la hora de meterle serrabillo a la primera N.
Muy bien, le ha quedado como si no hubiera un error.
No, no, no.
¡Es fantástico! Y el 04 con Tipex.
Esto ya es otra cosa.
Claro, es que aquí lo que entiendo es que el tatuador...
Quiso hacer esos reflejos como blancos que le han quedado...
Realmente mal.
Sí.
Y le ha metido Tipex al 4.
Es que es el primer tío que conozco que...
En vez de borrarse una parte de un tatuaje...
Se pone Tipex.
¡Chaoza! Se estoy pasando lo fatal ahora mismo delante de cámara.
Tú imagínate al pobre Jereo, tío.
Subir esa foto, presumiendo, y que ponga Fenn en ond...
presumiendo y que ponga Fenninon y la fecha mal puesta. Es que está todo mal, el Jero.
Todo mal. Que vergonza. Increíble.
Pues el primer hombre que habéis visto en
vuestra vida que le han aplicado Titex en la piel. En la 24-25 que os pensáis
que hemos terminado con el Jero. No, todavía queda. Jugaba en el FC skills de
sexta neerlandesa. Y este verano con 38 años ha firmado por el SV
Maddestein de novena. Seguimos bajando. De novena división que tiene 50 grupos
de 14 equipos, es decir 700 equipos. Está en una liga con 700 equipos. Es una
categoría en la que para que os hagáis una idea casi hay los mismos equipos que
los que participan en toda la FA Cup. Qué locura. Mira ahí lo tenéis. El Jero con
sus compadres. Bueno, ahí está. O sea, las pintas no hace falta ni analizarla. Hay uno
que va directamente en Crocs. Se ha venido de pescar en el río. El del moño. Joder,
es terrible. Es terrible la foto. Madre mía. Bueno, ahí lo tenéis. Es fútbol. Es que
no hay ni grada. No, bueno, no. Es lo más bajo del fútbol. Novena división. Bueno,
es un equipo recién ascendido. Nuestros amigos el Maddestein. En la final del
ascenso también resulta que hubo de todo. Hubo de todo porque para empezar su rival
en la final se había salvado en la categoría superior, es decir, en octava. Pero debido
a la participación de un jugador no elegible en dos partidos de la liga en los cuales solo
habían sacado un punto de seis. Ojo. Maciosos. Bueno, pues la Federación Holandesa ha decidido
quitarles cinco puntos. Ellos habían sacado un punto y les quitaron cinco. Qué pasó,
que tuvieron que disputar el play out para evitar un tercer descenso consecutivo. Bueno,
llega la final, el Maddestein ganaba 1-0 y uno del equipo rival, un jugador, se lesiona.
Tiran el balón fuera, todo ok. En la reanudación el equipo rival devuelve la pelota al portero
y el portero nadie sabe por qué, deja votar el balón y se le mete en la portería. Madre
mía, si esto lo ve Jan en Vila. Increíble. Le damos un normal delante de los micrófonos.
Increíble. Estuvo el partido parado durante diez minutos porque se pelearon a hostias
en la grada. Los entrenadores estaban discutiendo, uno pidiendo que el otro equipo se dejara
marcar y el otro diciendo los cojones. Yo no quiero descender, esto es un 1-1 de manual.
Se termina reanudando el partido al final con 1-1 después de diez minutos y en el último
minuto antes de la prórroga marca el Maddestein, se desata la locura, se lian a hostias en
la grada, pero a hostia pelada, terminan con los jugadores metiéndose en la pelea, aquí
lo estamos viendo, once policías interviniendo para separar a la gente como podían y todo
esto termina con el árbitro expulsando a varios jugadores, dando por terminado el partido
y el SV Maddestein subiendo a novena división. Increíble.
Bueno, en fin, no reímos porque esta banda es un normal, lo último que va al fútbol
es a ver fútbol y los hombres campay pegados entre vosotros y dejarnos en paz. Madre mía
de mi vida. Increíble. Madre mía de mi vida. Increíble. Madre mía. Qué historia, tío.
Bueno, el árbitro... No, no, decidió terminar el partido, yo lo he hecho. Agarro la roja
pero en realidad lo que debería agarrar es la Constitución porque aquí hay que meterse
mucha gente en la cárcel. Madre mía el Maddestein. Bueno, cuídate, el hierro. Sí, sí, el hierro.
Porque madre mía, qué destino has elegido, hijo. Vamos con otro que también le guardamos
un gran recuerdo, sobre todo por su paso por los Queens Park Rangers. Recuerdo muy bien
aquel año en el que bajó el QPR pero en cambio Charlie Austin se hizo un hueco en el corazón
de los aficionados del fútbol inglés. Aquella camiseta me encantaba. Era completamente contraria
cómo jugaba el QPR porque aquel QPR jugaba como la auténtica mierda al fútbol. Ya sabéis. Camiseta
más bonita, joven. Camiseta muy bonita. Elantero centro inglés de los de toda la vida jugó más de
100 partidos en Premier con QPR, Southampton y West Brom y Charles Vion ha pasado por Championship con
el QPR. Seis meses después estuvo en la Liga Austr... Seis meses estuvo en la Liga Australiana
y volvió a Inglaterra para jugar en el Swindon Town de League Two. En julio de 2024 volvió 15 años
después a la Non League para jugar en séptima con el AFC Totten y este verano ha firmado con el
Basing Stoke Town de esa misma división. El tío sigue divirtiéndose. Sí, séptima división inglesa no
es tanto como novena división de Países Bajos, no es tanta ponzoña pero bueno. Sigue siendo duro.
Sigue siendo muy duro. De verdad la sexta, séptima son ligas en las que no quieres entrar a campo.
Hombre, este no ha enfrentado todavía a Leandre Dahlmann. Ahí está Leandre Dahlmann, cuidado que mete hostias como panes.
Bueno, al Basing Stoke Town se le habían lesionado Nacho su delantero titular y el entrenador puso un
tweet mencionando a Charlie Austin de coña diciendo que si quería fichar con ellos que se habían
quedado sin delantero. Bueno, pues el caso es que Austin le interesó, un colega de Austin le abrió
MD al entrenador, empezaron a hablar y dijo que estaba abierto a fichar por ellos. Problema, no
tenían dinero para pagarle un sueldo acorde a lo que era la figura de Charlie Austin aunque estuviera
en esas divisiones. Decidieron mandarle un correo a los socios del Basing Stoke Town diciéndoles
oye tenemos esta posibilidad, queréis ficharlo, vale, si queréis ficharlo necesitamos pasta porque
no tenemos. ¿Y qué hizo la gente? Bueno, pues la gente llegó en masa con donaciones, recaudaron 21.000
libras y consiguieron su fichaje. Debutó unos pocos días después y lo agradeció marcando un
gole el bueno de Charlie Austin que ahí le tenéis entrenando con el Basing Stoke Town. Por cierto,
esto super random, te voy a contar el fichaje que intentaron en 2014. Bueno, no te lo, esto el
Basing Stoke Town, ¿qué? 2014, repito, noticia de la BBC, está comprobadísimo, no es fake,
me he metido, noticia de la BBC, 100% real, vamos a verlo Jesús. Ronaldinho, Basing Stoke Town,
beat to sign, Brazil legends, increíble, no era coña, el director de marketing,
Hood, dijo, echamos un vistazo a la lista de transferencias para ver qué jugadores
había disponibles, es decir, libres, de nombre Robin, nos quedamos en shock al ver que Ronaldinho
estaba libre y pensamos que qué mejor manera para volver al fútbol que jugar en el Basing Stoke Town,
sí, rotundo, increíble, increíble, somos terceros en la tabla y sería no solo bueno para el Basing
Stoke, sino también para la Only League, hombre caballero, sí, tienes los huevos más grandes que
Spartaco. Estoy absolutamente a tope, Ronaldinho se equivocó, la oferta del Basing Stoke. Me alegro
por Charlie Austin, que bueno, pues mira, ahí está el tío, también creo que también hace sus cosillas
como pandit en la tele, así que bien, tengo también la sospecha de que intentó arreglarse el tema del
pelo, pero ya está rafado al cero como diciendo, mira, esto ya, tengo buena cabeza para ser calvo,
pues ya está calvo. Y por cierto, recordar aquella famosa anécdota cuando en una discoteca pegó a
un tío por acusarle de meterse de droga. Vaya, también tiene por supuesto aquel día que delante
de los medios con el Southampton, estaba cabreadísimo y hizo una declaración ante Skye Sports,
creo que fue y luego le hicieron una canción porque tenía como el vídeo con su declaración,
en fin, una cosa muy local de Charlie Austin, que ya os digo, a mí es un jugador que siempre me ha
gustado porque es como de los nueve de toda la vida y que aquella aparición en la Premier estuvo muy
bien, luego ya pues tampoco fue para tanto, pero ya ha hecho más que yo en Premier League, ya ha hecho
más que yo, así que me callo la boca. Vamos ahora con otro delantero inglés, vamos con Jamie
a quien tenemos aquí en pantalla con el Norwich City hace 300 millones de años,
porque este delantero inglés jugó 17 partidos con el Norwich con los Canaries en Premier League en,
agárrate, 1994. Increíble. ¿Cómo es posible que mi amigo siga jugando? Bueno, pues ha cumplido
50 tacos esta temporada como entrenador jugador del Cambridge City de séptima división. Te informo,
Jamie Curtin es un jugador que ha jugado en todas las divisiones, desde Premier League hasta
novena división inglesa, en todas y cada una de ellas. Qué guapo es el récord. Increíble y es uno
de los ocho jugadores de campo ingleses que ha superado los mil partidos oficiales. Yo pido
un aplauso para este hombre porque tiene los huevos más grandes que para tacos. 50 años. Para que no
voy a pedir un aplauso es para el Cambridge City porque no ha llegado a jugar este hombre con 50
años al fútbol, era su sueño porque han decidido despedirle por el mal inicio de temporada. Acababa
de cumplir los 50 años, acababa de cumplirlo si le despedieron sin permitirle jugar. No se hace,
no se hace esto. Ahí está el pobre hombre. Bueno, agorra eh. Joder. Volporte. Te señala así. Hombre,
cualquiera no se lo cree lo que está contando. No sé qué está contando pero cualquiera no se lo cree.
Tú no vuelves a jugar nunca. El delantero soy yo. Chozas, no vuelves a sacar el balón jugado. Bueno,
en realidad no vuelves a hacer nada. No, vas a tu puta casa. Bueno, bueno, bueno y... Bueno,
con esto vas a flipar. Quedan dos, ¿vale? Quedan dos, pero son dos bonus tracks. Es una cosa muy
extraña. Yo te dejo. Vale. Lo que viene a continuación es el Precision FC. Precision FC,
un club británico en Emiratos Árabes Unidos. ¿Cómo os explica esto? Bueno, hay varios jugadores
de la Premier League en este equipo en el Precision FC de la tercera división de Emiratos Árabes.
Sospecho que esto es un nivel bastante por debajo de la octava división neerlandesa. Sospecho que
es bastante peor. Bueno, aquí están Matt Lawton, ex del Barley y del Aston Villa. Harry Arter,
Harry Arter ha acabado allí. Ex de Bournemouth, Forest, Fulham y otros británicos que no llegaron
a jugar en Premier pero sí han jugado en Champions League One y tal. Como Jamie Ward, ex del derbi,
del Forest. Joel Lynch con el Huddersfield, el QPR, el Brighton, el Forest y Ben Pringle. ¡La
patata! Hasta este verano incluso estaba Raybel Morrison, ex canterano del Manchester United,
ex ex del West Ham y que se marchó este verano. Trincador. Dato random hace unos días. Que escudo,
chozas, que escudo, que horror. Es un poco mierda. Hace unos días se anunció que en esa misma
división en tercera el Arabian Falcons fichó a John Joselby. Sí, me alegro mucho por él. Muy random.
Bueno, detrás de todo esto de un club británico en Emiratos Árabes está Sonny Cops, un canterano
del Brighton que es el entrenador del equipo y fundador del grupo Precision que ha estado más
de 12 años entrenando clubes en Dubai y vio un déficit en el desarrollo de jugadores y también
en las instalaciones. Así que decidió crear primero un centro de alto rendimiento que ha dado lugar a
este equipo que ahora mismo está en tercera. Es un club dirigido por ingleses en el Medellín Oriente,
es decir, el mundo al revés. Lo que está pasando pero al revés. El mundo al revés. Eso sí, aquí no hay
pasta. Entonces los jugadores a la vez que juegan tienen que trabajar hard. Ahí no se va. El bueno de
Harry Arter no se ha ido ahí a un retiro dorado. Madre mía. Bueno, de Matthew Lawton siempre está
con lo mismo. Es el autor de una de las mejores voleas que ha visto la Premier League. Buscada en
YouTube para todos los que no lo hayáis visto. Lawton Goal. Porque nos va a salir ese, creo que fue
con el Villa. Un pelotazo, un golazo increíble que ni Lawton ni lo creía. Pues te lo recomiendo. Y
Harry Arter en su día también me gustaba. Harry Arter, no sé por qué de estas cosas que almacenó
la cabeza. Me acuerdo perfectamente un día en el que Nathaniel Shaloba se pegó un cabreo enorme con
él en un Bournemouth Watford porque le dieron un pase atrás. Esto sobre los que llevan mucho tiempo
la media, se acuerdan. Le dieron un pase atrás, fue a rematar Shaloba y Arter, por detrás jugando en
el Bournemouth Arter, le gritó la típica de déjala. Y Shaloba la dejó pasar y cuando se
vio la vuelta y vio que era Arter con la camiseta contraria. Bueno, y se lo tomó Shaloba como un
antideportivo y Arter me estaba diciendo, el fútbol es palo vivo. Pero además era, pero llegando en la
frontal del área y para rematar. Y claro, veis que de repente la deja pasar. Espero que le pasa a Nathaniel Shaloba.
El highlight de la carrera de Harry Arter. Bueno y aparte de todo esto tenemos un bonus track.
Sí, porque ya no está jugando aquí pero tenía que meterlo porque se ha retirado en verano. Bueno,
se ha retirado, ha dejado de jugar en el Harbour of Town. Sandro Ranieri, ahí está el ex del Tottenham,
entre otros, QPR, West Brom. Estuvo seis temporadas en la Premier League, este medio centro brasileño
que también ha pasado por Italia, Turquía, Brasil y Portugal. Jugo su último partido profesional en
2022 y estuvo dos años sin activo. ¿Qué pasó? Que en un partido del Tottenham en el palco se
encontró con el bueno de Mitch Houston. ¿Quién es Mitch Houston? El entrenador del Harbour of Town.
Le dijo, oye, que yo estoy entrenando un equipo. ¿Te quieres venir por las risas? Pues le hizo
gracias a Sandro. Dijo que sí. Firmó un mes. Terminó jugando varios partidos durante toda
la temporada como, por ejemplo, la semifinal del playoff de Ascenso en el que nos fuimos a los
penaltis y él fue el encargado de tirar el penalti decisivo para el pase del Harbour of Town a la final
del Ascenso a playoff con el estadio abarrotado, las luces deslumbrándole. Ahí va un ex Premier League
y el penalti a la mierda. A tomar por culo y después nos eliminaron. Ese penalti nos daba el pase a la
final, maldito Sandro Ranieri de los cojones. Vaya penalti has tirado, coño. Salió en los últimos
minutos para tirar los penaltis y mira lo que hizo la mierda, la madre que me parió. Sandro, creo que
lo mejor es separar los caminos. Eso ha pasado. Volver al palco. Ha dicho Mitch Houston que el equipo va
volando y que tú vuelas a tu puñetera casa. Bueno, qué penalti. Qué penalti, dijo. Es la madre que lo parió.
Bueno, que amigos, coincidís que es el mejor guión que ha hecho nunca a Chozas. Imagínate el nivel
del rey. Quiero que la gente le diga en comentarios. Ascenso a Chozas, despido a Chozas, mejor guión de
Chozas, no estaba muy alto el listón, sí estaba alto el listón. En fin, nada buena. No sé por qué, pero gracias.
¿Jesús quiere decirle algo a Chozas? No.
Jesús no concede elogios. No. Jesús es un tío...
En fin, parco en palabras. Es la parca en general. Amigos, cuando seáis profesionales, los que nos estáis viendo
y estáis escalando en la pirámide del fútbol y luego bajéis, aparecéis en este vídeo. Necesitamos solo un
partido en la Premier. Cuando juguéis uno, ya entráis. Porque ya veis. El giber. El gerolía.
Tóquete los huevos. Así que os lo dejamos para dentro de diez años. Un saludo, amigos.